TVland sure isn't the cozy safe haven it
used to be in recent years dedicated
viewers have lost beloved characters on
everything from Game of Thrones to
stranger things to even Will & Grace so
far it looks like 2018 is shaping up to
be another small screen bloodbath
get the tissues ready because we're
looking back at a few characters who've
unexpectedly left us in 2018 but be
careful if you're not caught up on these
shows because this one's loaded with
sketch Karl The Walking Dead Carl Grimes
and actor Chandler Riggs for that matter
grew up on TV the son of Walking Dead
protagonist Rick Grimes he'd been with
the series since it started in 2010
along the way he endured tragedies and
setbacks including the loss of his
mother during childbirth the loss of an
eye and various acts of evil by villains
like the governor and negan keeping Carl
alive and safe was the reason Rick never
completely crumbled and Carl kept human
decency alive till the end which is what
ultimately killed him Carl's dead
Carl left Alexandria to help the
mysterious Siddiq mercy kills zombies
because Sadiq believed it freed their
souls turned out one of those zombies
took a bite out of Carl as zombies do it
was a death sentence but not an
immediate one giving Carl enough time to
say goodbye he hung out with his little
sister Judith wrote devastating farewell
letters to Enid Michonne and Rick and
then so his end could be on his own
terms he shot himself off screen before
he could go full Walker Tobin The
Walking Dead fans have always had mixed
feelings about Tobin a resident of
Alexandria who first showed up in season
5 on the one hand his relationship with
Carol was interesting but on the other
hand he just up in abandoned Francine to
a zombie attack in order to save his own
skin
well fans no longer have to feel
conflicted about Tobin because he's dead
thanks to an infected stab wound Tobin
turned into a zombie and killed several
of his former allies before being put
down for good by Carol talk about a bad
way to go out Simon The Walking Dead
there's an old saying among Walking Dead
fans lie down with zombie dogs you get
zombie fleas Simon found that out the
hard way as the second in command to the
Walking Dead's cartoonishly evil negan
it was only a matter of time before he
found himself staring down Lucille's
business end and sure enough negan
finally got tired of Simon plotting
behind his back leading to a one-on-one
showdown that ultimately ended with
Simon zombified corpse being strung up
as a warning likes Nick Clark fear The
Walking Dead fear The Walking Dead has
always played second fiddle to its
parent show The Walking Dead so in
season for AMC attempted to fix that by
bringing in a bunch of new faces along
with classic Walking Dead character
Morgan all those additions meant there
had to be some subtractions and the most
shocking was the loss of Frank Dillane
znik Clarke who was at the center of
many of the show storylines over the
first three seasons Dillon had
reportedly asked to be written off the
series though making it an easy choice
for producers who disposed of Clarke by
having Charlie a tween working as a mole
for a different survival group shoot him
dead
cigarette smoking man skinner andreas'
the x-files love it or hate it one
thing's for certain the x-files season
11 finale aimed to shock one of the
season's main arcs concerned cigarette
smoking man's plans to unleash a lethal
virus on the world and to pull it off
he'd manipulated Scully's shape-shifting
son William along with the FBI assistant
director Walter Skinner and agent Monica
Reyes into helping him execute it CSM
portrayed with ominous perfection by
William B Davis also happened to be
Williams's biological father yep he was
the one who drugged and medically
impregnated Scully nearly two decades
ago William wishing to be free of all
this evil awfulness finally confronted
CSM on a dock while using his powers to
disguise himself as Mulder CSM then shot
William as Mulder in the head then the
real Mulder distraught and devastated
shot CSM a bunch of times and shoved him
into the water this means that one of
this series biggest and most memorable
big bads is finally gone
however he caused some collateral damage
on the way earlier in the episode after
Skinner shot one time Scully replacement
agent Monica Reyes
the FBI assistant director was
apparently run over with a car driven by
CSM maybe honestly is anybody ever
really deceased on the x-files even
William bursts out of the water at the
end of the episode so who knows for sure
everyone still dies in the end
Furguson new girl Fox's new girl isn't
so new anymore
and it's come to the end of its seven
season run with a handful of episodes
that wrapped up all of its loose ends
and gave each of its characters a proper
send-off Nick and Jess have finally
gotten together for good
Schmidt and CeCe have a young daughter
named Ruth Winston and an extremely
pregnant ally are expecting and at some
point during the three-year time jump
between seasons someone passed away
Ferguson died of a heart attack
what yes the coroner said nothing about
Glitter you say coroner that would be
Ferguson the beloved smouched faced cat
belonging to Winston Winston acquired
Ferguson back in season two she belonged
to a girlfriend
and when she
on him he found peace by adopting the
cat while viewers were spared the not
very sitcom friendly images and
emotional turmoil of watching a pet pass
away new girl devoted an episode to
Winston's over-the-top grieving process
which involves a motorcade to an
elaborate memorial service conducted in
the Jewish tradition Spencer American
housewife a relatable family sitcom
injected with the hefty dose of social
satire ABC's American housewife concerns
a middle-class family trying to keep
their values and decency in check while
living in the ultra rich and superficial
town of Westport Connecticut the middle
child
Oliver is determined to be as rich as
his peers someday part of that involved
for finding a new neighbor a disgraced
wolf of wallstreet type just released
from prison named Spencer played by
George Hamilton while Oliver initially
intended to be just nice to get in the
old guys will a true friendship and
grandfather grandson relationship
developed he kept all of her in check
against the greed of the community which
is why it was so shocking that American
housewife writers had him passed away
late in the second season clayton Reeves
NCIS NCIS wound down its 15th season
with the heavily promoted plot the
departure of original character Abbie
whose longtime portrayer actress pauley
perrette was ready to move on
NCIS fans suspected that Abbie might be
written off the show the way characters
are most commonly and effectively
removed from a series by putting them
Six Feet Under
it certainly appeared that this fate had
befallen LabTech Abbie especially since
in what was Perret second-to-last
episode she and co-worker clayton reeves
struggled over a gun with a yet to be
identified assailant then a gunshot rang
out as the screen cuts a black
the following episode depicted ducky
sympathizing with another coroner about
the agony of performing an autopsy on a
former colleague and then as the body
bag is unzipped Reeves is shown inside
evidently he'd selflessly stepped in
front of a bee to take the bullet as for
Abby she was in the hospital but she
pulled through and played an integral
role in one last high-stakes
see is adventure Artie Goodman
unbreakable kimmy schmitt at the end of
season three unbreakable kimmy schmitt
resident grump
lillian had unexpectedly found true love
with Artie Goodman her rival and a
battle of her neighborhood
gentrification but at the start of
season four fans got a surprise when it
was revealed that Artie had unexpectedly
died leaving Lillian in charge of
disposing of his ashes she eventually
did it in her own signature fashion
selling two plastic baggies of his
remains for $1,200 to some folks who
clearly thought those ashes were
something a little more party friendly
Butch and Rea shall cool Gotham gets on
Gotham art frequent but they're usually
just underlings Stooges or random
victims of the future rogues gallery in
the season four finale though two major
bad guys bit the dust
Bruce aka the former solomon grundy was
executed by the penguin though being an
immortal swamp monster might reverse
that in future seasons meanwhile Rachele
ghoul was stabbed to death by Barbara
with a little help from the only person
who can kill him for good Bruce Wayne of
course riche also has a habit of
returning from the dead thanks to his
Lazarus Pit but for now he's among this
year's list of shocking casualties will
Simpson Jessica Jones in the first
season of Jessica Jones good guy cop
will Simpson turned out to actually be a
total creeper with a dark and mysterious
past that involved government
experiments gone wrong it seemed to his
being set up to become the comic book
antihero nuke that expectation was
confounded in season two though yes he
was totally stalking Trish but after she
confronted him it turned out he was
trying to warn her about someone even
more dangerous as someone who then
promptly snapped his neck so much for
that subplot Jack this is us due to the
show's nonlinear flashback heavy
structure the millions of rabid fans of
nbc's smash hit
tearjerker this is us knew that Pearson
patriarch Jack played by Milo
Ventimiglia was going to die but they
weren't quite sure how this is us used
its post Super Bowl timeslot to deliver
a very special episode on February 4th
revealing a
exactly what led to Pearson's passing
the previous episode ended with the
flashback sequence set in 1998 showing
the family's slow cooker short out and
sparked a massive fire that quickly
engulfs the Pearson home jack wakes up
in the middle of the night and turns
into hero dad
getting his family out of the house with
a bed sheet rope his wife Rebecca takes
him to the hospital to attend to his
minor burns then she steps out of the
room for just a second long enough for
an ER doctor to tell her that Jack
passed away of cardiac arrest brought on
by smoke inhalation your husband went
into cardiac arrest it was catastrophic
and I I'm afraid we've lost you we're
not ugly crying you're ugly crying
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]